the mcu storytelling is so generally
successful that you may have ignored
tony stark objectifying black widow or
the hulk dabbing or the bodily fluids
covering the milano keep watching for
more mcu missteps natasha romanov aka
the black widow is one of the most
capable characters in the entire mcu
which is just one reason why it's so
cringe-worthy that her introduction
revolves almost entirely around her
being objectified by tony stark
including a bunch of needlessly
gratuitous lingerie modeling photos oh
and maybe the worst line in the whole
mcu i want one
i want one outside of the gross surface
level objectification of those three
words it doesn't help that his love
interest pepper potts happens to be the
person to whom the line is delivered
johansson herself acknowledged her own
role in how the sexualization of
superheroes developed while doing press
in 2019 for black widow needless to say
her outlook on the character has changed
a lot over the last decade it's hard
because i'm inside it but probably a lot
of that is actually from me too i'll be
35 years old and i'm a mom and my life
is different obviously 10 years have
passed and things have happened and i
have a much different more evolved
understanding of myself that's one big
reason she wanted to return to the mcu
for a black widow solo film to help
change the narrative around female
superheroes in general and black widows
specifically it's changing now now
people young girls are getting a much
more positive message but it's been
incredible to be a part of that shift
and be able to come out the other side
and be a part of that old story but also
progress
of course cringe-worthy quotes about
black widow aren't limited to mcu
characters we've heard them from mcu
actors as well while doing an interview
with digital spy uk in advance of 2015's
avengers age of ultron captain america
actor chris evans and hawkeye actor
jeremy renner made some pretty tasteless
remarks about scarlett johansson's
character when digital spy asked them a
question of dubious seriousness about
mcu fans shipping black widow with both
cap and hawkeye renner decided to go
full locker room with his response jesus
let's
say something along that line
though the remarks were apparently meant
in good humor they came off completely
tone deaf especially considering
complaints about the depiction of the
character to that point both actors
faced an understandable amount of
backlash for their respective remarks
via social media and each issued a
statement
for his part evans gave a heartfelt
apology saying that they quote answered
in a very juvenile and offensive way he
added i regret it and sincerely
apologize
renner on the other hand issued a
classic passive-aggressive non-apology
which made it clear he thought the
backlash was dumb i'm sorry that this
tasteless joke about a fictional
character offended anyone who's not
meant to be serious in any way
i'm talking about a fictional character
and fictional behavior but conan if you
slept with four of the six avengers no
matter how much fun you had right
you'd be
still no apologies for his music career
however
you'd think marvel would have learned
from those controversies but guess which
character they mishandled yet again in
avengers age of ultron one of the least
beloved plot developments in the entire
history of the mcu was the sudden weird
romance between bruce banner and natasha
romanov in avengers age of ultron while
both characters are each separately fan
favorites their relationship seemed
ill-fitting especially given that their
most memorable scene together up to that
point was a sequence in avengers where
hulk chased natasha around trying to
murder her but that uncomfortable fact
hailed in comparison with the horribly
tone-deaf scene in age of ultron where
natasha tells bruce that she's a monster
too because thanks to a forced
hysterectomy she can no longer have
children you still think you're the only
monster on the team
needless to say many fans and critics
didn't appreciate the idea that
natasha's value as a human being
extended only as far as her ability to
bear children marvel made a small
attempt to address the controversy in
the film black widow but given the
nature of the multiple controversies age
of ultron director joss whedon has been
in over the past few years this scene
has actually gotten even worse with age
rather than better
speaking of bruce banner perhaps the mcu
went more than a little bit overboard
and trying to convey what a dorky is
besides burdening him with tons of
nonsensical science jargon in multiple
films natasha romanov just straight up
said it in age of ultron which you'd
think would've been enough he's also a
huge dork
chicks did that
but apparently this wasn't enough
because marvel went out of their way to
make the new improved professor hulk
seem even dorkier in avengers end game
when we meet hulk five years after the
snap bruce has figured out a way to
merge banner's intellect with hulk's
body giving him the best of both worlds
yet he's still a walking dad joke as
evidenced by the fact that when
approached by a group of kids for an
autograph he does the dab
oh go
bruce
damn
the dab which became popular as a fad in
2015 was already cringingly uncool when
the movie came out in 2018 the fact that
he dropped that move in the film's 2023
setting yeesh
this one is a little forgivable with the
help of context after tony stark frees
himself from the captivity of the ten
rings in the first iron man movie he
tells pepper potts he wants to do two
things i've been in captivity for three
months there are two things i want to do
i want an american cheeseburger
and the other that's enough
when they arrive for a press conference
tony's driver happy hogan dutifully
trots around the car so tony can
retrieve another cheeseburger from the
burger king bag really you're held in
captivity facing certain debt only to
cobble together a super suit from spare
weapons parts engineer an escape plan
survive a trip through the desert and
you hit up the bk drive-thru before
facing the media of course the main
reason this scene was so cringe-worthy
is that it was such a blatant product
plug as the first film of the mcu of
course marvel needed all the help it
could get to make sure their first film
turned to profit but this was wayne's
world level stuff contractor no i will
not bow to any sponsor
ironically iron man actor robert downey
jr has actually credited burger king
with helping him get sober because their
burgers are so terrible that he realized
he had hit rock bottom in 2003 after
eating some of their food he told empire
the whopper was so terrible he ended up
throwing all his drugs in the ocean it
was such a disgusting burger i ordered i
had that and this big soda and i thought
something really bad was going to happen
john favreau director of the first two
iron man movies chose not to return for
iron man 3 which was written and
directed by shane black originally
though favreau had intended to make iron
man 3 and he had hoped to use the
classic iron man villain the mandarin
and favro had already alluded to the
baddie in iron man with the ten rings
organization a nod to the character's 10
magic rings that give him power but
black went a totally different direction
using both the ten rings and the
mandarin as red herrings in iron man 3
the terrorist known as the mandarin
actually ends up being a british actor
named trevor slattery who was just hired
to play the part of a terrorist it was
all a shell game to keep tony stark
chasing his tail while the real villain
aldrich killian moved behind the scenes
for many fans it was unsatisfying and
even a slap in the face marvel had to
make amends by putting out the all hail
the king short film as a promise to fans
that wait there is a real mandarin so
don't be too mad this finally paid off
in chongqi in the legend of the ten
rings but it took years to get past this
cringe-worthy mistake
speaking of cringe-worthy blunders how
about the time star-lord basically
killed half the living beings in the
entire universe because you know what
we're talking about in avengers infinity
war the guardians of the galaxy team up
with a group of avengers to try and take
down thanos and their complex plan
actually works perfectly up until the
point where star-lord totally screws it
all up after learning that his
girlfriend gamora was killed by thanos
in his successful bid to get the soul
stone star-lord selfishly made it all
about his feelings abandoning the plan
so he could get a couple ineffectual
punches in punches that thanos probably
didn't even feel but the rest of the
universe felt it because star-lord
selfishly going off script allowed
thanos to free himself and ultimately
snap half of the universe out of
existence understandable sure but that
didn't stop angry fans from taking out
their displeasure on star-lord even
after no thanks to him the avengers
later fixed everything so will fans come
around when star-lord returns in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 or has
this idiotic moment ruined the character
for good time will tell and while we're
on the topic of star-lord we also need
to point out that he's really really
gross sure it makes sense after all
peter quill never knew his father and
his surrogate father was a blue-skinned
alien pirate named yondu who kidnapped
him so it's understandable that quill
might develop certain antisocial
behaviors like being disgustingly
unhygienic at times in fact he seems
oddly proud of it or at the very least
uncaring when gamora remarks on the
general disarray of his ship the milano
in the first guardians of the galaxy
movie after the group discusses selling
the orb which contains the power stone
star-lord's green hued love interest
informs him that his ship is filthy
instead of taking offense as one might
imagine he leans into it oh she has no
idea
find a black light
a place would look like a jackson
pollock painting
pollock of course was a painter renowned
for making art by splashing and spraying
paint willy-nilly everywhere and since
black lights will cause certain bodily
fluids to glow the kind we can't really
spell out any further
ew
we accept and acknowledge that captain
america aka steve rogers is a man from a
different era turned into a super
soldier during world war ii he spent
decades frozen in ice after crashing a
bomber into the ocean he's technically a
nonagenarian he admits he was in a
barbershop quartet and he's definitely a
bit naive at times when it comes to the
ladies but while the star-spangled
avenger is as wholesome and all-american
as apple pie there's no real reason to
think he's a square prude so while the
whole language gag from age of ultron
was good for a quick laugh we're not
sure it really makes that much sense at
the end of the day
fury you son of a [ __ ] oh you kiss your
mother with that mouth
think about it there's absolutely zero
doubt he'd have heard a lot worse while
fighting alongside enlisted men in world
war ii he led the legendary howling
commandos in the mcu do you think they
were howling gosh darn and heck when
things didn't go their way would he have
stomped to admonish them as they faced
off against the german army and hydra
the language joke and its subsequent
repetition just come off a bit forced
and try hard check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]